ça va et aucun signe d'agressivité donc
a pas de problème quelques semaines
auparavant c'est un couple de rhinocéros
noirs comme cela qui a été abattu en
plein jour à quelques centaines de
mètres d'ici des braconniers les ont
liquidé à coups de kalachnikov ils les
ont tués pour revendre leur corne sur le
marché noir c'est une catastrophe c'est
une catastrophe parce que parce qu'en
plus ils les tuent pour rien parce
qu'ils pensent que la corne de
rhinocéros en
ondes et ils s'en servent comme soi
disant comme médicament est en fait s'il
savait que la corne du rhinocéros est
comme un nombre c'est exactement la même
chose donc
c'est du gâchis c'est du cash et de
rhinocéros liquider une première en 25
ans d'existence du parc de lewa
les braconniers ont laissé les animaux
mourir pendant plusieurs jours mais les
rangers du parc sont intervenus et les
ont empêchés de récupérer leur butin
pour cela ils ont découpé eux mêmes les
cornes
cet homme en uniforme et celui qui a
découpé les cornes il s'appelle john et
c'est le chef de la sécurité de lewa il
possède un trésor de guerre un peu
spéciale
pour le découvrir il faut pénétrer dans
un coffre-fort blindés au code secret
[Applaudissements]
à l'intérieur se trouve ce que
recherchent tant les braconniers des
défenses d'éléphants et les fameuses
cornes de rhinocéros qui représente une
véritable fortune
voilà ça c'est une corne de russie 1 kg
ça vaut 7000 $
il attend donc si on parle d'une corne
comme celle ci des soignantes on arrive
à près de 17 20 mille dollars sur le
marché noir kényan
des blacks maquette année fumée à
l'étranger ça vaut bien plus
à l'étranger ses cornes peuvent se
revendre jusqu'à 30000 dollars le kilo
notamment au yémen ou en chine ils en
font soit des fourreaux pour les
poignards soit de la potion aux vertus
soi-disant miraculeuse
ceux qui tuent des rhinocéros ne le font
que pour les cornes
ils ne se servent pas de la viande ce qu
ils ne se servent pas de la gare casse
ni de la peau siess verts rien d'autre
que les cornes
ils tirent sur le rhinocéros couple
accorde un texte il s'enfuit il
s'appelle pour lutter contre ce trafic
john peut compter sur ses hommes on les
appelle les rangers ils forment une
petite armée et sont prêts à mener cette
guerre
une guerre qui se déroule sur un
territoire immense grand comme deux fois
paris
en tout 250 km² de savane de forêts de
montagne et des braconniers qui s'y
cache et n'attendent qu'une chose tuer
leur cible principale ces rhinocéros ou
encore ses éléphants qui se croit ici en
sécurité malgré les 300 personnes qui
travaillent pour le parc les oies et
très difficile a quadrillé
heureusement les rangers sont
parfaitement entraînés comme de vrais
soldats ils sont équipés d'armes
automatiques et utilisent des techniques
de commandos
[Musique]
accompagné d'elodie il accepte de nous
montrer l'une de leurs cachettes
dissimulés dans les sous-bois leur
campement et plus que sommaire c'est
d'ici qu'il surveille de jour comme de
nuit la zone la plus fréquentée par les
animaux
ils sont là pour protéger les rhinocéros
tout simplement
ils sont là pour que les braconniers ne
rentre pas dans la réserve et cesser
leur métier c'est-à-dire qu'ils
patrouillent sans arrêt sans arrêt pour
pour être sûr qu'il ait pas de braconner
cars et si l'on croise un c'est sans
aucun problème qu'ils utiliseront leurs
armes
si l'un de mes rangers vous un
braconnier en train de tirer sur un
rhinocéros ya la route qu'il a le droit
de faire feu
avez vous déjà tiré sur un homme inconnu
je ne veux pas parler de ça
vous savez si un homme est sur le pont
il faut bien se défendre ces chiffres à
ce qu'il ait d'abord tu tires et après
tu parles c'est normal
mais mélodies n'est plus choqué
chaque année une vingtaine de
braconniers sont officiellement tué au
kenya à les oies nous n'en saurons pas
plus en revanche john accepte de nous
présenter son arme absolue pour
débusquer les tueurs de rhinocéros si un
braconnier perd une affaire personnelle
et que le chien la renifle il est perdu
où qu'ils se cachent il sera retrouvé
régulièrement l'équipe est le chien une
casquette pour seul indice
l'animal doit retrouver le plus
rapidement possible son propriétaire le
sac en plastique c'est pour que le
ranger ne contamine pas l'odeur de la
casquette et perturbe son flair
elle renifle sait où elle est maintenant
[Musique]
le résultat ne se fait pas attendre
l'animal c'est exactement où il doit
aller
[Musique]
l'homme est rapidement interpellé et mis
hors d'état de nuire
évidemment tout ceci n'est qu'un
exercice ce qui est bien réel en
revanche ce sont les braconniers locaux
qui s'en prennent aux rhinocéros